i'm here to help us get our sauce on
please welcome chef oh and james beard
award-winning author one of my very
favorite chefs on planet earth carla
lolly music
thank you
thank you so much
i'm just gonna say it again when we
started cookbook club on the show i took
a picture of myself with a cookbook to
represent my love of cookbooks who is
the cookbook carla
so you are one of my culinary heroes
thank you you're now new friends on the
show the second time you've been here
and you are gonna teach us yeah how to
become you know
take stewardship yes of being able to do
this for ourselves you're gonna be a
regular monster i love ragu
i think the most important thing about a
ragu and we're just browning some meats
we got our brazil our braujoule
um i think one of the most important
things about aragoo is that it's
personal and we actually didn't have a
family history of making ragu but it was
one that i created when my niece was
born as just a ruse to get her over
there on sunday afternoon so i could
spend more time with my family and like
that's what it's really all about and
being together like the whole thing is
just a magnet to like get the people to
you right yes yes well and when you're
an incredible chef i'm sure they're
magnetized anybody can do this so let's
start with our brushol this is a beef
short rib and it's pounded thin so
brazil could be beef it could be pork it
could be whatever so we're going to take
a little piece of parm a little salt and
peps and our side first just a shout out
to my best friend a parmigiano
parmigiano reggiano and then you salt it
and i salted inside for you a little
pepper and then you're just going to
take your twine
and so this is a roll-ups not everybody
does fragile some people do meatballs
some people do uh pork chops so it's
really like up to you meatballs to me is
like a lot of work and rolling up the
the brazil is not no this was extremely
unintimidating yeah and the short rib is
really nice because it's so like fatty
and delicious so that's why what's
happening in here is so fatty and
delicious i'm all about fat i love i
love fat
i
i'm with you all right so now that this
is browned we'll just take it out
we already have a um
pork shoulder steak which was browned
beautifully and into this mixture you're
just going to drop in your onion and
garlic okay and kind of get that pan
dripping action get it all going
so one of the things about that sounds
so good is is that in every recipe i'm
going to teach you
how to use the down time to like do
something else so
yeah the time that it takes to brown the
meats is like 12 15 20 minutes
you don't need to just be standing there
you could be chopping your onion and
your garlic while that is happening
carla have you tried that paper wet
paper towel trick with chopping the
onion
no what do you do with it oh my god you
guys i i think i learned about it plenty
enough on tick tock we had the pasta
water hack on tick tock with keeping
your colander in the pot
so you take a sheet of paper towels get
it wet rinse it squeeze it out so that
it's a nice damp surface put it on your
chopping block yeah and chop your onion
on top of it the water underneath in the
paper towel will absorb the acids and it
works okay
i'll try it
[Applause]
i've tried everything else
[Music]